- What's that?
(audience cheering)
Should I say hold on?
My producer is trying to get my attention.
Is that for sure?
Really? This is crazy!
Right now?
That's insane!
Ladies and gentlemen, this is amazing.
Of course, you're all
familiar with Aquaman, right?
Okay?
(audience cheering)
Yeah.
I've just been told, listen up,
I've just been told that
Aquaman is about to spawn
right here on stage.
(audience laughing)
This is insane!
It's, yeah, it's mating season,
and he's decided to do it right there!
Okay, hold on!
There he is!
There's Aquaman.
King of the seven seas,
monarch of the oceans.
He's swimming around,
making sure the area is safe for his mate!
This is fascinating.
And here comes Aquawoman.
Aquawoman!
(audience cheering)
Here she comes!
She is clearly swollen with eggs!
- [Andy] Oh, laden. My goodness.
- After a brief courtship ritual
where they just sort of look at each other
and have a courtship ritual,
she releases her eggs onto the sea floor
while Aquaman stands guard!
There she goes!
(audience cheering)
The eggs have been released,
and now it's Aquaman's turn.
He hovers over the eggs!
(audience groaning)
I said, "He hovers over the eggs!"
(audience laughing)
And carefully deposits his aqua-sperm,
or milt...
Over the eggs!
There you have it!
(audience cheering)
Aquaman
(chuckling) has successfully spawned!
Oh, so beautiful!